attention is more fundamental than
consciousness
yes then it comes before
so consciousness is the expression of
attending
if you don't attend if there is no
attention at all
then there can be no consciousness you
can only remember these things as having
been conscious that you attended to
right and uh
also it's not sufficient that you
attended to them you also need to store
the things that you attended to in such
a way that you can recreate them later
in the context of having attended to
them so you basically need to have an
attentional protocol that integrates
over all these experiences
and so you have an attention agent
living inside of the control agent
and this attention agent is basically
living inside of your mind okay wait
sorry sorry hold on so you have a
control agent and that control agent
controls the attention no uh you have a
control agent that controls the organism
at large the big elephant okay okay
let me you're just you're teaching me
right now this is these are office hours
there's a control agent then there's
attention and the control agent controls
the organism yes and the mind is the
expression of attention the mind is uh
in the way i use the word is basically
the the software that runs on your brain
or that emerges over the activity of
your brain so it's the entirety of the
mental processes and uh you could think
of it as the operating system okay and
there's a difference between mind and
consciousness yes so the mind is the
whole including the other consciousness
yes okay okay
and yeah so i would say unconscious mind
makes sense as a term right so uh most
of the
of what happens in the mind is is not
conscious yeah and there's also uh
maybe we should go into this separately
but maybe we should do it now there is
this very big issue uh
what does it mean to be conscious right
it's
it's unimaginable that the physical
system like the clockwork could become
conscious how would the physical system
become conscious something that leibniz
describes for instance uh with a
metaphor of a mill imagine that your
mind was like a big mill of all these
moving parts and so on and you enlarge
it in such a way that you can enter it
and you see all these mechanical parts
pushing and pulling against each other
there is nothing in there over which
feelings and emotion and perception
consciousness could arise
and
this is a very strong intuition that
also drives uh source chinese room
argument that i think is a reformulation
of leibniz intuition